[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qu'elle fait
6 heures pas croyable
au même instant là que tu arrives tu
viens tu j'en sais rien comment ça tu
n'en sais rien on a je cours je vais je
viens aux idéaux j'en peux plus c'est
tout ce que faisait donc c'est tout ce
que tu trouves à répondre à six heures
du soir un coup de l'est soit explique
l'expliqué quoi expliquer que je
t'attends depuis deux ans a pu
téléphoner tout de même c'est toi qui
l'avais dit cinq mois j'avais dit deux
heures car l'amour à deux ans moi ça me
coupe la digestion est avec quelques
snacks comme d'habitude non mais tu pas
pour un idiot ça serait trop facile
gillet jeunesse tu veux m'expliquer ce
qu'il s'est passé
alors explique vasile invente raconte
j'écoute donc depuis deux heures de
l'après midi mon mari me suis ça va ça
tombe mal il est rentré dans les moeurs
mais j'en sais rien mais tu te dois dire
du tout mais est ce que tu me laisse le
temps va bien tu vas passer par le
jardin à nous mêmes robin a tué parfaite
voilà alors juste une paire de suture
ravissante pour toi je risque de me
faire écraser 20 fois pour éviter les
passages cloutés
parce que méticuleux comme et françois
est en manque jamais grâce au cloud je
le sais mais j'arrive pourquoi pour rien
pour un môme qui trempe de trouille dans
son pantalon fripé parce que tu as peur
tu as peur de recevoir une bonne raclée
bah dis donc si tu crois que j'ai peur
de tomber tout aux trompes lourdement
d'ailleurs telle qu'elle lui dire de
venir à ton mari tu verras comment je
vais le recevoir
on a sonné
on a sonné la découvre c'est sûrement
lui je file dans la salle de bain où vas
tu as tu me dis-je ou films dans la
salle de bain vous disions si celui-ci
quand même pas moi qui vais l'ouvrir
mais moi je le connais pas ton mari
qu'est ce que je vais lui dire tout bas
toi tu le connais on sait que c'est
toujours mieux quand on se connaît mon
flanc de pamfou nom à l'allée ouf c'est
peut-être pas lui et puis si c'est lui
invente
c'est la seule chose que ça vient faire
les hommes alors profitez-en allez quoi
[Applaudissements]
vous n'avez pas des boubous le sergent
vous savez beau boulot mais en fait ils
savaient pas t'es sérieux je vous aurais
pas déranger bull vous mais il n'est pas
là à la fac mais si elle avoue je vous
dis qui départagent pas qu'est-ce que
vous avez monsieur jacques vous avez
l'air tout chose non j'ai pas or je vois
j'ai vu la petite dame entre et après je
comprends je comprends je suis femme
nancy vous allez vous me rappelez quand
j'ai épousé l'hérault avec ben ouais le
voulais tu as forcément il est si beau
si distingué il a de l'instruction mais
forcément on n'est pas agent de police
qui veut alors non militaire mais lol
mon amie line tête comme ça pourquoi je
me disais ça vous monsieur pas à ben oui
c'est ça pour vous dire quand j'ai
épousé les oc bassin de travail est
tellement les onze une disette ou tant
que j'étais mélomanes avaient tellement
bougé mieux la musique
ah non tellement j'aime et leon
la femme enfin et du mélomane oui c'est
pareil bon enfin je suivais partout
comme ça nous faisait qu'ils ne
comprennent pas et ne voteront plus non
c'est un one quoi c'est moins au
hautbois la voilà malone à obala voilà
n'avait pas vu allez viens te dérange
ces messieurs-dames glacis bah oui c'est
de la céramique
excusez moi quand j'ai pas les contacts
bon eh ben je vais faire mal et voilà et
puis je reviens faire vôtre mais non non
non non non ça ne passe pas à tout à
l'heure et on amusement tu peux revenir
c'était la concierge
oui bah dis donc bien avoir affaire à
elle qu'elle tomba pas et moi il doit
être rentré maintenant alors je prends
une douche épices fils ont fait trois
touches tu peux la prendre chez toi tu
sais bien qu'elle marche plus haut
enfin coup de saipol une fille sam aussi
attendu toute la journée
tarifs sur par mois j'ai apprécié en à
moins qu'une fusée arthur ils ont le bol
les maris ou les abords on est toujours
les sacrifiés vallat la prochaine fois
que tu passeras devant le mont
rez-de-chaussée tu ne t'arrêtes rappaz
tu continueras tout droit jusqu'au coin
de la rue là il ya un man avec pain
touch this in les jeux les petits
masseur turquie est diplômé bac est et
doit même y prendre pension y rester
tout à dos ce que tu veux je te parle du
hammam et pourquoi de la rue n'y a plus
tout frotter nova tu vas voir tiens tu
vas voir si je vais être franc tendo aux
non pas une fin en soi
ah bon tu m'appelles françois maintenant
paire de manche est nulle
non pardon mais tu sais tous les matins
françois me frotte le dos ou grand
chaque bombe importants comme ça non
plus non mais continent noir est alors
tu restes sont froides plus fort non
mais c'est jury s'est juré nouveau musée
pas raisonnable que barbe à papa de
[ __ ] la paix remake d'un courrier sous
la porte
mais tel courrier sur la porte mais bon
voilà voilà voilà j'arrive
[Musique]
pour moi tant que ça croyez moi france
soir au boss au fait ça alors avis donc
pas une surprise surprise
la dernière fois qu'on s'est dressé
comme il ya six ans c'est pas il ya dix
ans n'a pas changé non plus à la vie à
la mort à ce moment c'est sa mort d'un
gage si tu manges et la rage qui trouve
bien à ça c'était en sixième avec toi
souviennent kaka totor attente aura le
prof de sciences naturelles avaient su
qu'il s'était endormi sur son vélo en
cherchant une grande tortue dans la
forêt de senlis la bd y avait des
grandes tortues dans la forêt de senlis
imbéciles c'est le nom d'un papillon
alors qu'est ce que tu fais là
qu'est-ce que je fais là c'est vrai que
là bas si je cherche ma femme siesta oui
je cherche ma femme tu avais un je dis
tu cherches un boîtier j'ai beau y aller
et voilà une tête tu te souviens pas
leleu l'opéra l'opéra qu'on avait monté
ensemble pour la noël tu jouer la femme
je jouais la femme
ah non non non non non non que je suis
bête s'était pas toi c'était la fleur tu
sais que je le vois tout le temps la
fleur je l'habille tu l'as dit oui je
suis son casting y chante en fa ba
l'alcazar nonce après la fleur et si
j'ai bien compris l'approchant gr
y a pas de danger glisse marié nord je
suis pour qu'il se passe il en a deux
alors dis moi tu es marié oui
félicitations mauvieux déjà lignes à 13
années tu te souviens de ma vie ah oui
c'est elle non mais lui ressemble je
trouve pas un non non non nous nous
retournerons temps pourtant autant
monique l'été bouaine autant christine
la nouvelle interpréter blonde alors il
faut changer la couleur du costume le
vert l'état
le verdict en question raconte à le vert
l'étain c'est ça ouais c'est pas pour
toi toujours dans la ville
axe que ce bois francs soit tu sais pas
je suis accablée de travail avant je
termine le décor d'une pièce et costumes
à l'autre alors alors coincidence pas tu
me parles but de monique et l'interprète
de notre spectacle s'appelle également
festive
celle que le verre est un c'est ça me le
vert l'état dis moi qu'est ce que tu
deviens dans la vie à part de mariage
bien tu permets que je t'en prie import
export à bas s'est intéressé au sein et
qu'est ce que tu veux plus rien ah bon
c'est intéressant ça vous fait voyager
les lézards japon la mairie ou et enfin
non non la petite banlieue château mont
rouge le vésinet tu vois un terrain je
suis vanné je travaille comme un fou
crévale ce piteux le début de
l'après-midi moi je sais mon dieu non je
je je sais mon dieu ce que c'est que le
travail à netapp a quelque chose de la
boîte ensuite parce que déjà on doit
avoir soif sais pas je regarde attendait
t'as rien entendu
cette chauffe-eau le chauffe eau
elle était pas tout seul en dix mois qui
se piquent un sentier du mois qui avait
été commise et là c'est la femme de
ménage un bon tu veux tu vas whisky non
je préférerais une citronnade a donc on
va leur vient faut que je la prépare
dans la cuisine c'est loin non tout près
bah ouais ben écoute moi je préfère
rester là je suis vanné j'en peux plus 1
ah bon et ben alors j'y vais dis donc
t'es tellement content de me retrouver
que tu me large plus tôt voilà neuf ne
vous dérangez pas le mari de continuer
je vais dans la cuisine et je reviens je
reviens tout de suite tellement là mais
qu'est ce qu'il fait j'admire dit quoi
hardy dont les ravissantes hamac est là
ces mots quelle pièce ça c'est pour le
mari ne compte pas ce que je suis grand
tarbes osmets tu peux même pas imaginer
quoi
combien de citron 1 2 alors 3 et sans
sucre 1 parce que je suis un régime pour
mais l'une pour maigrir j'ai pris
quelques kilos il ya quelques temps tu
sais qui te vont très bien et au web
assez pour la ville ni quoi ni tom c'est
ma femme qui installe toi ouest à toi je
mains des prix alors heureux j'en ai
fait pépin voir et je hais je retiens
c'est ce que je retiens tout de suite
c'est ça non mais je sais qu'il m'a dit
tu reviens problème
qu'est ce que tu as un qu'est ce que ça
vous met à la porte de la salle de bain
c'est à donner un choc a apparemment
pour françois je te jure si j'avais pu
prévoir qu'ils pouvaient les salaires
mais j'en écoute je pleure mais je te
comprends mon avis n'a jamais cessé même
si je dis que je devine tabone tabone
mon mieux tout nu allongé par terre la
tête sous le tapis de bain tu peux pas
savoir ce que ça peut être drôle de se
trouver nez à nez avec des faits ce
qu'on connaît pas toutes les fesses sur
s'emballe alors là c'est une erreur une
grosse migraine ainsi tient un exemple
au hasard à nicole ma femme et ben de
dos nu dans un tunnel en plein
brouillard je la reconnais tout de suite
ah bon rôle en pointe mais alors par
contre tu vois le parcours je préfère
nettement la chute de reins de tapptic
dont celle de nicole ah ben ça c'est
peut-être passé notamment mes remarques
des fans de nycole bien les très bien
même mais celle-ci a quelque chose de
plus de plus juvénile tweb plus
inattendu dans la vie de plus luxuriants
un voyageur et voilà le mot sur yon
tirait ridant tu t'en ben toi quand tu
travailles pop qui solo parallèle
reçoivent je sais pas du tout ce que tu
imagines à mais j'imagine rien je
constate simplement que ta bonne et tout
dessus et tout nu tu trouves ça normal
toi merci une fois soit je ne sais pas
moi je sais pas elle me lave son linge
elle a dû en profiter pour la bêtise tu
sais que les former à blain
mais on finirait par croire non mais que
tu sais quand on était jeunes on
surnommait le poète on avait bien raison
je me souviens qu'en las cases c'est la
sq avec las cases et moi on avait
découvert comment vous et les enfants tu
nous a répondu mais vous êtes sous on
prend un grain de blé bien mûr un
coquelicot une parcelle der du temps un
peu de ciel bleu de la kantari dans nos
féminines boulette on avale et voilà
l'enfant à ses grands pères qu'ils
avaient raconté grand père il en émaux
citron amis dit l'ancien t'intéresse
paul peut être moi je me sacrifie une
belle ta femme à bas voire un faux pas
faire ça non non non non tu as raison ma
faim non mais la joie de te retrouver la
chute de ravin j'avais complètement
oublié ce qui m'a amené ici qu'est ce
que je te dise en arrivant ah oui je
cherche matin et oui elle a un amant oh
mon pauvre vieux alors si je tombe sous
la main je lui dis cela car il n'y a pas
trop tiff
mais non mon argent suppose a battu voix
faut pas se faire des idées j'en suis
pas sûr mais je le suppose alors cet
après-midi mode la suivait un salon
évidemment elle elle se faufilent entre
les voitures dangereuses
battu par nan moi pour vous et qu'on ait
passage clouté et mange la paire
forcément alors comment plus elle a un
entraînement de coureurs à pied tu
imagine la difficulté à nommer c'est
incroyable ce que les femmes peuvent
avoir de vitalité quand il s'agit de ne
rien faire mais c'est assez pâle à
défaut enfin bref bref je croit la
reconnaître au coin de ta rue tu sais
juste devant le ventura zones matures
comme cet épisode alors tu es en
retraite prôné une touche avec alex türk
qu'est ce que t'es rigolo alors j'ai
fait tous les immeubles de ta rue en
commençant par les huitièmes tiens
pourquoi mais parce que l'amant mon
p'tit vieux la manse invite toujours les
étages élevés
la mancelle septième ciel c'est le
soleil le grand air la liberté vers pur
temps avec nous les maris nous sommes
les rampants les besogneux les poussif
ça on monte les escaliers coude au corps
souffre le rapide et jarret tendu
allons allons françois tu es jeune femme
et moi j'ai pas loin de 1 mais ce qui
doit se faire dans les eaux là plus que
ça à mon avance passé et puis et puis là
je n'ai rien à voir dans cette affaire
un mari c'est toujours dieu sait jamais
je ne dis toi bien se nommer regarde toi
tu as l'air d'un gamin à côté de moi et
puis toi tu es libre tu as toutes les
chutes de reins de la terre à ta
disposition vous les amants pour vous
maintenir en forme vous faites l'amour
nous les marées il nous reste la
gymnastique ou la citronnade bonoumin
nous allons françois moi qui habite à
rez-de-chaussée jeu pour être mariées
aussi d'en avoir la tête à aa et c'était
sais tu pourquoi tu habites à
rez-de-chaussée vin nouveau est ce que
t'as rien à cacher que ta vie est au
grand jour
et puis tu veux que je te dis me dis
faut souhaiter ben je vais dire t'es pas
un véritable âme ans à bosser pour
gentil de me dire ça mais non mais aimer
alors les autres parce que tu es trois
purs et puis les autres les vrais tu
sais pourquoi ils habitent les étages
élevés
ben tu le sais on françois parce qu'ils
ont pas de vis-à-vis ces [ __ ] voilà
eh ben dis donc
j'ai bien fait de garder mon rez de
chaussée voilà six mois après les
huitièmes qu'est ce que tu fais benj
décembre je descends un c'est même ce
qui nous a donné la joie de nous
retrouver
[Rires]
quand je suis arrivé ici j'ai entendu de
musique douce
la lumière tamisée les rideaux tirés je
me suis dit ouh là là où la glace est là
ça sent l'adultère le plombage verrez un
an et puis alors je t'ai vu j'ai vu le
poète là j'ai vu ta gueule qu'elle a ma
gueule bata point google damman telle
gueule de copains bien amant saint-james
et une gueule de copains surtout pour le
mari âgé pas une pipe dames angers pas
une tête dommages et peine de première
dame et remarque j'ai quand même eu un
petit doute quand j'ai entendu le bruit
dans la salle de bain
oui bah ouais surtout il a pas duré
longtemps monde les faits je m'assure
pieux qu'à ouvrir la porte
dis donc tu as pas le laisser dans cet
état
quelle étape enfin la revêtu pour toi la
panoplie de l'amour j'espère que tu vas
tu exécutes et puis va le sport comme ça
sinon elle va sans rhume et n'est pas
tout ce qu'il faut sous la main d'yves
en moelleux musique vous serez 2-2
françois mougeot travail - un travail je
travaille toujours à la lumière
électrique à décor de voyage avec les
feux de la rampe
voilà j'exécute mieux comme ça ah ouais
ouais bah occupants dont des corps on
est bien d'accord
oui la rue du bac sa côte est ont tout à
côté bon parce que nicole à sa meilleure
amie rue du bac alors j'y fais un
souverain pour voir si dès l'abord enfin
mon vieux ah non non non non non je
reviens à non je reviens et je te la
ramène pour te l'a présenté ça fait
plaisir
tu as pensé le plaisir luxuriant aux non
vraiment alors il ya quelque chose de
plus de plus luxuriante su rien mais m
enfin bordeaux que je me taise que je me
taise
quand j'apprends que françois me trouve
avec la première paire de fesses venus
qui est en l'occurrence la tienne te
ment mais quelques temps avec lui en
cinquième puis jeu chez toi et moi seule
qui te trouvais dans la salle de bain
raison de plus justement alors que tu
peux admettre toi kahn l'homme qui vit
avec moi depuis six ans avec moi qu'une
chute de rage vinyle inattendue du riant
quelque chose de rare d'unique une pièce
de musée donc tu peux l'admettre toi que
cet homme ne soit pas le dernier des
mufles pour ne pas l'avoir remarqué au
bout de six ans enfin mon jeu c'est à
croire qu'il va jamais revenir
kim aurait reconnu qu'il avait vu
matthew ebden qui bat à tête basse sous
le tapis demain eh ben tu as eu la
présence d'esprit
non j'ai dit c'est du maroc ue maroc ben
oui j'écoute et contre la porte
le savon dans la main le savons a glissé
oh ben non
le salon est tombé et ben dis donc tant
mieux on l'a échappé belle
parce que ça te fait rire and on and on
and on non non ça me fait pas rire je
souffre c'est ça c'est moi qui m'a somme
et puis c'est toi qui souffle fait faire
une chose pareille à mon meilleur ami
d'enfance ça justement justement alors
ça c'est magnifique
comment ce magnifique du huitième mais
c'est magnifique que françois soit son
meilleur ami
parce que maintenant on n'aura plus
besoin de se cacher en vidéo maintenant
on va plus faire l'amour comme des
condamnés qui attend de grand
inquisiteur parce que le grand
inquisiteur le mari len me dis donc
c'est ton meilleur ami ben non c'est pas
magnifique c'est pas très bon ce que tu
dis danser la vie au bébé va la vie
n'est pas belle parce que figure toi que
moi françois je laime bien d'ailleurs
c'est justement parce que je les aime
bien que je n'aime plus j'oubliais je
téléphone sur sept de 7 mais lui sait
pas où tu sais mon ami qui habite rue du
bac
françois viens de te dire qu'il a neigé
allo duceppe c'est toi françois et la
non mais je peux te parler il est papa
de toi bon qu'est ce que tu lui as dit
génial génial
elle est géniale et bien lui dire que je
sortais de chez elle mais bon tu le
retient oui le plus longtemps possible
et tant que je rentre chez moi
voilà merci ma chérie à charge de
revanche
ah non non non non non là vraiment je
trouve pas non à peine moins demain
matin si tu veux mais vraiment chez moi
tu sais c'est pas c'est parce qu attends
attends tu peux pas lui prêter son
appartement samedi de 3 à 6 pour un
rendez vous avec qui avec qui avec
marcel qui se savoure ce qui cessa
marcel assez marcel non je connais pas
elle a beaucoup d'ailleurs enfin il
paraît qu'il a de bonnes références à
l'heure soit gentil
bon ben on entendit tuera salue jack
voilà ma chérie tu embrasses voila voila
tout va bien françois ne se doute de
rien bon ça que je fis lundi moi tu veux
dire à françois que tu organise un
déjeuner pour qu'il te présente sa femme
lequel femmes
ben moi mon chéri tu as une chance de 1
alors qu'ils connaissaient pas en
profiter enfin de mon meilleur ami
d'enfance il va pas recommencer
il ya des milliers de femmes qui
trompent leur mari avec leurs meilleurs
amis
seulement elles elles le savent 1 nous
le savait pas alors tu vois bien qu'on
n'est pas fautif dans ce déjeuner va
être à 37 déjeuner sera délicieux
c'est moi qui vais le faire tu sais que
françois a raison de surnommer le tue a
une sensibilité
il ya peut-être de plus en plus d'hommes
qui trahissent leur meilleur ami mais
des poètes
il y en a de moins en moins n'est pas
être font pas l'amour il en parle
bon le sûr quand même vous arriver j'
attends de quelle sorte pour venir bien
mais je commence par le yak devrait en
avoir besoin
allez on sait mois ont cassé tout les
sommiers 10 dont vous savez que j'ai
retrouvé beaucoup oui dans mon four qui
s'étaient calmées n'ont heureusement que
l'avait pas à lui même non non non non
non non non non ne poursuit pas 0-0
c'est fini tous les coups mais non mais
c'est beau talent vous abaissez et puis
ça fait passer le temps plus vite vous
trouvez pas moi je m'ennuie jamais écrit
mes mémoires
ah oui je mènerai retrouvait à dublin
que c'est jacques j'ai une idée déjà oui
laissez le ménage et donner juste un
petit coup à la salle de bain dites moi
madame la cueillette est ce qu'on vous a
déjà dit que vous aviez une chute
d'oravig survient j'en ai et bien on va
vous le dire
[Applaudissements]
ce jour là qui ça pour toi
la petite dans la salle de bain au bien
sûr et ta femme
ah oui j'arrive de ses cheminées de
cession à 1000 us est une fille très
sérieuse oui oh oui elle adore son mari
c'était bien la peine d'avoir couru
toute la journée nicole sortait de chez
elle mais je les ratés peu de gens
regrettent pas d'avoir couru toute la
journée ça nous a permis de nous
retrouver
alors on va fêter ça tous les deux entre
homme et tout ce à quoi je pense pas
pourquoi je pose et l'avait alors demain
tu nous invite à déjeuner oui comme ça
je te présenteras ma femme arabe à oui
je suis très content de la connais je
suis sûr qu'elle paiera la tap une
petite course à faire aussi site
françois justement je vais acheter des
pinceaux et je rapporte une beauté voilà
non parce que moi je vais le donner
je vais aider est un nudiste faire sa
lessive dans cet ennui pop lui donne un
petit coup de main des trucs tu vas lui
faire plaisir surtout que je crois que
vous allez passer un bon petit moment un
site souviens quand on était jeunes ou
partager toujours nos billets on disait
plus tard quand on sera grand on se
partagera la même femme cette fois ça y
est mon dieu c'est écrit à recette est
écrit qu'est ce que tu attends fait une
tête non non ça m'amuse
eh ben on va préparer notre petite bombe
alors qu'est ce que tu préfères
champagne à champagne bon et ben alors
du champagne c'est parfait tout est
parfait tu aimes le caviar en caviar
c'est un peu cela moi j'aimerais bien
une bonne petite terrine de canard
l'organisme va alors terrine un petit
camembert et du champagne et youpi alors
ne te bouscule pas ne revient pas trop
vite
dis donc les domestiques se font rares
alors me la fatigue pas trop ça me
dérangeait pas si jacques je vais
chercher ma lessive dans la cour
[Applaudissements]
vous dérangez pas monsieur jacques jeux
move est le courrier sur la teta vous
voulez que j'ouvre les rideaux dites moi
hier soir avec votre copain j'avais fait
du tam tam
vous étiez donc on pète ah ben voilà
vous avez sabrer le champagne
ben ouais ben dis-donc fallen invités
moi j'aime bien un petit coup de temps
en temps un effet comme délai aux autres
le vin c'est le sens du travail hors
lits dont vous empêche pas de dormir
imposé comme ça au ca me passer de la
fête
vous savez pas qui hier soir est un
cinglé café tous les étages en demandant
malades nicole durand prend faut 10 dom
rendez compte si la décennie chez vous
un bain il aurait trouvé madame nicole
durand on aurait rigolé bon allez je
vais faire mal ici
à ses côtés comme sa femme sur chaque
abattant mieux tomber
j'avais peur d'avoir vexé jeu je vous ai
pas avec ces au moins non vous êtes son
ami oui a dit dans les deux sens j'avais
fait un ramdam hier soir vous entendez
chanté depuis ma loge est-ce que vous
chantiez au juste
ça les entraînements on va vous savez
l'adultère c'est toujours la même
chanson que tu as écrit une chanson de
circonstance avec monsieur durand vous
auriez vézère un lion comment vous
appelez appelle françois
oui françois durand
la bouche alors là vous savez moi sur ce
que je disais c'était pour cause et
nagent comme dit comme délai aux cinq
ans qu'on dit les 11 communes et de coke
gaffe irna la pire des manières affirme
à la diane caron des comptes sur
françois si en plus celui-ci affirme non
mais moi c'est pas non pas pour excuser
madame nicole à 6 mais comme je dis
toujours en ce sens là on dit pas mal de
sons walla n'a pas fait ça méchamment
non non non il a fait sans faire exprès
c'est toi bah oui c'est moi sorti des
eaux là la caisse contenait qu'est ce
qu'on fait qu'est ce que t'es contenait
quelques secondes mais qu'il contenait
elle parle comme un disque usé ont une
bonne cuite 7 réussit pas trop les
cuites
tu vas soyez ton fois ouais tu es passé
ouais tu sais que je t'attends toujours
pour déjeuner avec ta femme
oui la loi est furieuse que tu es des
couches et ta femme
ouais tu passe chez toi mouais bon ben
alors soyez là pour une heure je sais
pas si je parle comme un disque usé les
trois matata bois comme un vieux chien
puisque ce que ce quota sur la tête
c'est un bat pas pour quoi faire
ça fait tenir les cheveux enfin l'afsset
est complètement grotesque
bah ouais j'espère que madame la
cueillette n'est tout de même pas la
donne hier soir pourrait causer d'ennuis
et puis c'était l'autre là là le cocu
mais pourquoi j'ai tout dit g mais vous
lui avez dit tout le bien avait dit quoi
j'ai pas parlé longtemps elle va me
davis et la tête il a dès hier soir 6
oct aps le village a vu débit sera la
tête
oui çà çà çà c'est vrai il est très vite
partis ont su les volcans rester molko
et injuriée nous insulter moi je
méritais football quand je vous dis
écoutez votre corps et vous étouffer la
valeur attendent
[Musique]
il ya des ratés this à françois on pense
qu'apres en soit il m'a pas rater du
tout ah non mais j'ai pas couché chez
moi pour me venger
quand je pense que j'ai attendu monsieur
jusqu'à 10 heures du soir après lui
avoir préparé son vice préfet rey des
pâtes au jambon enfin si j'avais su
j'aurais dormi ici avec toi et bain ou
quoi nous en sommes qu aurait pu donc
quoi qu'est ce que tu veux dire
françois est au courant par toi mais non
pas par moi la concierge lui a tout
avoué ce matin ce matin françois
accouché la has et françois qui a poussé
l'un à bombay alors pourquoi m'a pas
téléphoné il était saoul il avait oublié
son numéro de téléphone
et toi mais tu connais tous numérotés
les vannes pour cathy lui a pas donné
enfin qu'outre était tout de même pas
moins donné à franchement le numéro de
téléphone de sa femme
si l'on a compris tout sur deux buts aux
un peu plus tard sa mort évite et de
coucher avec un personne à personne
or en la personne du set enfin moi je
passe mes nuits à une demande des weppes
françois qu'elle conçoit j'arrive
j'arrive très détendu pour apprendre que
mon mari a couché avec mon amour pardon
pardon écoute il accouché ici
oui ou non il a couché sur le divan tu
as fait coucher françois delacroix dit
tu as fait coucher francs soit dans
notre lit tu me dis alors là tu me dis
enfin qu'est-ce que tu vas imagine mais
plus là où es tu couches et ben moi j'ai
couché dans la chambre du fond bon du
tout pourquoi tu avais dit en arrivant
que françois mais vert râpé tu l'avais
envoyé me chercher non je t'ai dit que
tu avais raté parce que je croyais qu'il
partait tout est foutu et françois aubin
france soir est incapable de tuer
françois mon dieu c'est naître le plus
dur le plus compréhensif et plus le plus
in drug se connaissent ben alors
pourquoi choisir un autre pour comparer
tu sais quand une femme trompée elle
trompe toujours par excès de fidélité je
comprends pas oui on met les hommes
comprennent jamais rien à la mécanique
féminine ça c'est bien connu
tu comprends françois c'était pour moi
je sais pas moi un être un être
d'exception
je me disais c'est pas possible c'est
l'amour ça un bandeau sur les yeux quoi
on regarde les autres hommes
je te regarde et puis je me suis rendu
compte que toi aussi tu toi aussi tu est
exceptionnel sap a quelque chose à voir
mon nom
quand t'as pas un petit fond de whisky
tu sais quand tu es une femme choisit un
homme pour l'amour c'est qu'elle la
trouve exceptionnel dû payer même si
c'est pas vrai d'ailleurs c'est françois
qui a commencé le premier temps me
tromper en eau dans son auréole en me
couchant à ne plus le regarder comme un
héros mais comme un mari je crois que tu
exagère un peu là non non
une femme de trente jamais avant de
sortir qu'elle s'est trompée sur l'objet
de son amour donc une femme qui trompe
c'est qu'elle se prend tu comprends mais
chez toi tu penses honte à duper souvent
mon pauvre chéri bas avec toi ça prend
une bonne demi douzaine avec moi pas
parce que tu as battu chantier de
manerbe non je te préviens pas je te
mets en garde contre qui contre toi mon
chéri 10 dont tu sais qu'il est bientôt
miletic a invité françois déjeuner et
crois moi les émotions lui coupe pas
l'appétit
je vais faire les courses pour les aînés
chacune est folle course françois
revient qu'est ce qu'il va se passer
puisqu'ils c est ce dont jamais écouté
ça ne sais pas je ne sais plus et la mer
la cueillette casse mais totalement une
ariane est bon alors je t'ai les foies
de la maison parce que sinon on finit
plus allo carmen madame monsieur est là
bien 25 ans jacob oui au rez de chaussée
encore merci carmen et bien tout va très
bien
voilà françois est passé à la maison il
a dit si vous voyez madame qu'elle me
rejoignent 25 rue jacob nous y déjeunons
qu'elle apporte ce qu'il faut alors tu
vois tout va bien françois ne se doute
de rien bon allez les filles
dis moi tu tu vas dire à françois que
que tu l'as vita tout à l'heure mais
s'il arrive avant moi non s'il arrive
avant moi surtout tu m'as jamais vu faut
jouer le jeu jusqu'au bout on a mon dieu
qu'est ce que je fais sur treize jardins
pour elle je vais acheter un poulet 1
pour 3 c'est encore ce qu'il ya plus
avantageuse
voilà merci
part en voyage prend soin à non non non
violent je te demande l'hospitalité
ah oui je te demande l'hospitalité parce
que j'ai découvert que nicole n'est pas
rentré de la nuit je retrouve un vieil
ami de collège n'en profitent pour des
couches et alors je m'en vais et je
m'installe chez mon vieil ami mon cela
me voilà dans mes remarques est elle
aussi était peut-être chez une amie à
nonant les femmes n'ont jamais d'amis
elles ont toujours une même robe ou un
même homme qui les sépare alors nous
vous dont elle ne sait pas encore il
faut qu'à vous dit que tout c'est pas
parce qu'elle est ta maîtresse au au
petit peu moi je suis sûr que c'est la
concierge qui te raconter des horreurs
pourparlers est la vôtre et n'importe
quoi la concierge
mais quelle concierge et m'a rien dit du
tout à consière plutôt deviner à quoi tu
me prends pour un imbécile
françois fillon mais pas du tout parce
qu'on prend toujours les maris trompés
dont les abeilles sont en jeu tout est
faux de dire ça tu fait appel d'abord tu
n'es pas un imbécile avec toi non c'est
vrai mais avec les autres invités tels 7
puis françois puisque tu es si si
gentilles six copains suis une femme je
vais te le dis elle voulait pas petit ça
je peux puisque tu sais je te le dis
elle sort d'ici le sortent ici comment
elle aussi recoucher là mais non mais
non elle a couché ses échelles et son
ami lucette par vengeance voyant que tu
ne rentrait pas elle aussi a voulu des
couches et par vengeance mais alors elle
est à nouveau même thème françois ruel
mots mais oui mais je suis sûr que si tu
avais vu son pauvre petit visage inquiet
grattage et toi aussi tu sais toi aussi
tu aurais eu de la peine donc oui la
pauvre chérie way et aux risques elle
est maintenant perçu faire l'écho ce
qu'on le déjeuner et ben ça par contre
une bonne idée parce que moi j'ai une
faim de loup mais c'est ce qu'est la vie
bah oui j'ai toujours faim - si tu
savais comme nicoud part gentiment de
toi ni coups
winnik ou jeu là je l'appelle je
l'appelle nique en fait c'est nicole
plutôt que j'appelle nicoud c'est
amusant ça parce que moi je l'appelle
nikki aussi tu savais comme elle parle
gentiment toi elle t'aime beaucoup tu
sais non ni coni qui me colle à elle
elle a dormi chez son ami lui cet ehpad
ils ont en main un poids en moins et moi
de ouais merci
mais pourquoi membres as tu pour te
remercier leur merci mais oui mon vieux
tu m'a apaisé tu m'a ouvert les yeux moi
je vivais dans l' angoisse l'imaginait
moi ce [ __ ] énorme muscle est colossal
oui j'étais jaloux mais jaloux l on
mettait tout mais pas du tout puisque je
te lis je suis très content si content
que c'est parfaitement nicole était
incapable d'aimer un seul homme à la
fois alors je préfère que l'autre ce
soit toi hein parce que toi moi je te
connais toi tu es un peu moi tu es très
gentiment oui et puis alors toi tu es
l'ombre d'un hameau ça c'est vrai une
fois par semaine enfin je te dispense de
tes précisions l otage avait parlé de
moi à non au violon sa chute je suis
désolé un jamais
non je suis compréhensif mais enfin
faudrait quand même pas exagérer son bon
des petits machins et ton régime
tu te fous de moi non non mais tu chef
françois moi je suis pas vraiment fautif
non mais non elle non plus c'est l'amour
qui est coupable mais oui l'amour tout
seul sans ennui l'amour au bout d'un
certain temps ne souffre plus la
solitude
tu vois moi je suis un vrai - j'admets
l'amour tel qu'il est et je le subis
bah oui bah évidemment toi t'es pas le
mari non françois françois françois je
te jure un jeu toujours pensé que
c'était toi tu entends jamais alors
jamais jamais ou aussi du mois quelle
idée de la pluie durant tu t'appelais
bouddha dans les affaires je préfère
l'anonymat surtout dans l'import export
sont indispensables alors j'ai pris une
nouvelle fille de nicole et durant ya
pas plus anonyme
ah bah oui monsieur c'est tentant d oui
mais enfin tu comprends moi j'aurais
mieux aimé que nicole s'appelle bouddha
mais on fait avec notre fatigue pas
puisque je me tue à te dire que je ne
reproche rien au contraire je suis très
content mais font se fâche mais je te
jure toute la nuit j'ai rêvé à ce dos
que j'avais entrevue dans ta salle de
bains j'étais très déçu quand tu m'as
dit que c'était ta femme de ménage
le lendemain au réveil quand j'ai
découvert la vérité j'ai pas pensé
nicole me trompe
j'ai pensé ce corps magnifique
appartient à ma femme tu aimes le potage
une quel rapport non chez moi je déteste
le potage chez les autres jeunes sont
délicieux ah non mais je vois pas du
tout ce que vient faire le dos de nikon
dans ton passage bat simon greul a suffi
que je vois nicole chez 72 texte est
elle pour lui trouver un corps
magnifique mais l'habitude on veut
l'habitude c'est ta trace sa et mousse
le des halles à la tiens devrait
supprimer les journaux les journaux
henri la lecture du journal
quand je pense que je lisais mon journal
devant nicole devant ce corps que c'est
monstrueux non je suis monstrueux vu
d'ailleurs c'est bien fait pour moi ce
qui m'arrive alors là je n'ai pas volé
non mais tu es masochiste pas du tout
mais pas du tout puisque je te dis que
je suis très heureux enfin presque
c'est vrai nicole même elle va arriver
dans un instant nous disant qu'un poulet
pour toi c'est encore ce qui est plus
avantageux
nous deux on est très heureux de s'être
trouvé un bien sûr nicole thèmes aussi
mais enfin tu vas être gentil avec moi
tu t'arranges rats pour me faire croire
qu'elle t'aime un peu moins que ces gens
soient moi je ferai tout ce que tu
voudras 1 je m'efface jean bourrel je me
com allez y en ait pas question sa chute
interdite comment nicole ne va sûrement
pas tarder à arriver alors je te prie le
fait de bien vouloir changer de tête
1 tu ne sais rien je ne sais rien et tu
vas voir tu vas voir quelle grande
comédienne ce peut-être alors là on va
bien rigoler non à nos caves et ça je ne
me plierai pas à cette comédie grotesque
dont je me plie bien moi mais c'est
pourtant moins qu est le plus mauvais
rôle alors le bush ne bouge pas je veux
les ouvrir et tu va assister à une
tranche de vie des plus passionnantes de
la comédie humaine
la femme adultère dans sa scène de la
mieux réussie le pensons bonjour mon
chéri
[Applaudissements]
les origines marie marie c'est celui-là
oui non et passer l'autre n'est ce pas
monsieur jacques oui à bord duquel morte
ah ben c'est à dire moi je croyais que
ce matin là un fait divers est si vite
arrivé ben oui mais je voyais encore
dans paris dimanche la morte à mémoire
et sous les bons alors attention
attention attention ça peut vous coûter
assez cher de manque de respect un
protecteur de la société ça peut vous
coûter assez cher
moi j'avais toutes les campagnes mai 68
et paysans les commerçants et gauchistes
et nudistes
alors si vous croyez m'impressionner
avec un crime passionnel
parce que moi le crime passionnel c'est
la spécialité
bon alors yat-il humains ou pour meurtre
enfin presque
dans l' écoute ghislaine ne plaisante
pas avec le travail le travail c'est
sacré alors pas de cadavre pas de paul
adey vu le cadavre et c'est à dire je
remets il est têtu il est têtu c'est un
sanguin
la belge c'est le meilleurs outils du
jardinier et macadam
c'est le meilleur outil du policier ne
saisira pas alors je réitère où m la
morte elle est partie chercher un boulet
non non non pour le fonds le pour le
déjeuner mais enfin mais enfin de quoi
tu mêles du enfin quel âge avait vu au
sival s il fallait s'occuper en plus de
la mort des gens qu'on connaît pas il
fait une taille gueule et allez ça veut
dire en soi pas les adore son miroir à
travers toute faite au macadam amarg jeu
quand même pas me tuer consoeur plaisir
non mais tu te sens
alors il est parti faire les courses
pour le déjeuner mais continuez à vous
payer ma dette très bien c'est parfait
aux ovins l'attendent et bien au froid
dont un verre à notre ami l'a doublé à
whisky d'un service bon bah tu vois il
veut pas insiste aux couples dont je me
dis que tu as enfin le mari et l'amant
qui se tutoient comme de vieux amis de
mieux en mieux mais nous sommes de vieux
j'aime beaucoup mon objectif au mieux
comme ça hein et sans doute après vous
allez faire un bon petit déjeuner à
trois petits déjeuners de famille de
première communion comme une autre mais
c'est mon grand choix aux basques
annonça alors que supporter à 10 ans
passe et un but lafleur
oui à fleurs du mâle est surnommée la
fleur coupée fleurs coupées s'il vous
plaît mon dieu
enfin au lieu choisi par le président
une surprise à la vie à la mort
franchement justement gestion grâce à la
race qui suit tu m'en souviens au violet
quand jacques hardelay napoléon je
m'étais jour des filles mais quand
j'étais pépin le bref mettez bertrand
président du nom du candidat euros j'ai
la chance de savoir que des lions et
pour la grande catherine surnommait la
sémiramis de l'homme s'était tu as des
pierres de 1,3 dont pardon excusez moi
si je m'immisce l'a lâché après
l'histoire de france vous vous attaquez
à l'histoire grecque alors la viola a et
celle à qui ça
oh
le vieux censeurs alors non
on a dansé le mari de ma mentionne
attention cette magnifique frédéric
lafleur léonce l'accueil nous étions
fait on ne rencontre c'est le
commissaire bossu bon écoutez le des
types de votre espèce là mon pays
on savait comment il s'appelle non
deschamps le contraire saisissez le
rapport non non je vous montrais mes
rapports puisque vous ai fait moi
puisque je lui ai fait j'ai toujours des
zombies et de séjour ne me suis pas
d'accord avec toi les gens creuserait je
vous est allé bien trop tard je me fais
expulser des papilles gagna sa géant des
prêts relais dans un quartier
respectables barbus les travailleurs
adeptes il dessine pas dans l'été entre
eux
1 ils ont une femme ou une maîtresse
quelquefois les deux noms en tout cas
personne des taux courts on attendait
une personne et surtout pas les
intéresser ces rapports bah je vais
rédiger une pétition je vais vous faire
expulser un et joe contraire il se
rapporte
est-ce qu'il est méchant tiens je vais
lui envoyer une vipère dans un petit
paquet moi je resterai j'aurais juré que
c'était la police nous détestent n'était
pas un coup d'état
on s'en souvient votre vie on sent quand
même parce que ça le regarde pour moi je
vais vous dire ils nous envient
mais n'osent pas alors ils sont jaloux
on va pour une surprise c'est une
surprise est merveilleuse
c'est merveilleux pour trouver tous les
deux ensemble on sera jamais douté ya
longtemps depuis le collège c'est
merveilleux quelle fidélité quand même
ah ah oui alors à part ça dis donc
qu'est ce que tu deviens toi tu chantes
arrêté mais tu chantes habillant ça a
complètement complètement avons nous une
gare d'eau que jacques martin visé des
perruques de toutes les couleurs j'en ai
des blondes des rousses des marées
vertes
d'ailleurs ça je suis très soigneux tous
les jours changent de perruques alors je
la vois je l'aimais asséché à ma fenêtre
bon c'est ce que dit le locateur les
gens sont méchants quand même alors la
cantatrice chauve on fait sécher sa
moumoute
ou bien tiens tiens quand j'habitais au
trocadéro il m'appelait la folle de
chaillot
moi aussi je mets plus probablement pour
lieu avoir mangé des petits compensation
penser je suis re sur la société du
monde entier oui j'ai été j'ai été
chantée à longwy un viking en panne à 60
et ben margot jah connaît actuellement
tout est encore plus intimement un
ministre on va le répéter à buddh à rome
et aurait des ennuis avec le
gouvernement l'ayant est ton nom de
chanteuse c'est frédéric lafleur nom
martin martha phone berton similaire de
richard wagner ger passion bord et ça et
tu le chante
richard bien sûr bien sûr ce sont 19 à
l'alcazar mais en play pas arrêtée à
cette fois c'était alors là tu vas voir
son numéro est très au point vous
attendez notre artiste c'est une
illusionniste
oui nous sommes ses partenaires oui
chérie on peut ensuite j'ai dû m'arrêter
chez duceppe pour téléphoner à la maison
parce que notre idiote de femme de
ménage m'avait bien dit de faire les
courses pour le déjeuner elle n'a pas
été capable de me donner le bon numéro
j'ai dû faire tous les immeubles de la
rue tu veux pas me débarrasser mais si
tu y connaît écoutez françois m'a
tellement parler d'eux
quand je vous considère déjà comme un
intime
je suis très touchée françois maire
fumades d'arrêter propre devoir garder
françois tout le match c'est du propre
terre je me demandais où il ya deux mois
j'étais folle d'inquiétude mais pendant
ce temps là vous vous amusiez je
voudrais bien savoir à quoi mais je le
devine il réussir - tas de femmes avec
amazon on ne dit rien j'ai un instinct
infaillible et puis vous avez plus en
plus et ton régime à lomé on a on a
mélangé champagne citron ou ou bien me
sens pas combien de citron moitié-moitié
six bouteilles de champagne pour un site
on est tu veux ressembler un poudlard
vous voulez qui ressemble à un bouddha
rabatteurs
nous avons joint norme c'est vrai parce
que c'est ça oh pour le dorlote et les
amis vient tout gâcher
on part de roujan monsieur enfin si tu
me préfère désormais enfin vous dire on
en parle plus on a parlé plus mais je
vous en donne beaucoup je lui en veux
pas savoir
parce que sans lui françois n'aurait
jamais des couches et vous savez ce qui
mériterait mieux que je prenne un amant
c'est pas vrai mais françois de l'argent
si c'est bien je ne ferai jamais je ne
suis pas chez moi je ne veux pas faire
l'histoire
surtout chez anna parce que vous êtes
artiste un jeu blanc
vous l'avez deviné entre aujourd'hui
même bon on se reconnaît tout de suite
vous aussi je crois une vision ministre
nous dit on ne mens pas je pourrais je
suis très à droite dit non joli joli la
maquette sait pour quelle pièce aussi
une histoire d'adultère en corniche avec
du terreau je déteste ça et dans la vie
monde youtube et ses jeunes ni chez vous
je nettoie on ne te casser deux fameux
te montrer série lé maître de maison
c'est lui faisait bon chez moi je suis
un vrai chat noir
pour soi mais pourquoi tu disais rien
beaucoup de colère mois bon alors je
t'en prie nom alors je t'en prie
présente mois présente mon ami jacques
cendier mon vieil ami jacques mais je
vous connais je le connais mais oui il a
il a déjeuné à la maison l'hiver dernier
menteuse
pourquoi il n'ya jamais mis les pieds à
bord on s'est rencontré un à côté vous
avez une fête que je connais
je passe très souvent dans votre rue
j'ai une amie qui habite à deux pas
lucette baron vous connaissez pas du
tout pas du tout ce n'est rien les amis
de mon mari sans mes amis je disais
droit monsieur routine alors qu ils s
si un vieil ami frédéric lafleur une
véritable réunion du collège s'était
d'ailleurs c'est fou ce qui peut faire
jeune ton ami jacques olala un vrai bébé
et agréable
c'est exactement le genre d'appartement
ou j'aimerais habiter
quelles différences france ô avec ton le
blé or tu as tort de me présenter les
amis c'est bien installée parce que de
nos jours une femme est beaucoup plus
sensible un appartement et celle amusant
non écoutez denis terrien il est
adorable certainement un honorable
et puis si pratique c'est vrai avec
chaussée c'est beaucoup plus pratique à
8e
bah oui on peut faire passer cette idée
a mis par la fenêtre voilà j'espère
françois c'est à ça que servent les amis
d'enfance près de son appartement de
temps en temps pour organiser des
petites sauteries ne dit rien françois
je déteste le mensonge
on sent une main féminine ici quelqu'un
qui vous avez beaucoup souffrir
tu vois françoise dupin toujours mais je
ne me prends pas mon chéri je suis aux
premières loges
oui vous êtes marié peut-être monsieur
non non non non non il n'est pas il
n'est pas marié mais il a une petite
amie qui a une chute de reins
extraordinaire et alors elle déjà avec
nous mais non mais non elle ne peut pas
son art il avis marié je vous félicite
pas désuni n'a pas que des femmes
mariées
il m'a présenté une petite ingénue de 18
ans il l'habille pour son prochain
spectacle thomas il a un problème le
vert l'état n'a pas sa part ça les les
fonctionnels tels comment elle s'appelle
long
lui dire de me quoi il ya pas de mystère
christine oui je savais pas
comment pourrais-tu le savoir ma chérie
oui ça bien sûr
illusionniste l arrivée à tous les trois
ans est é du ciel dit abbas est encore
une petite amie de monsieur il est
terrible mais si mais si tu est terrible
il est terrible mais cumule on dirait
pas important pourquoi comment tant que
tu un charmant ça alors absolument
charmant mais pardon pas du tout mon
genre
et vous monsieur la faire vous êtes
mariés vous savez faire la cuisine au
japon j'en étais sûr vous allez me oui
la cuisine c'est pour moi oui la cuisine
monsieur tu prend le couloir et alors tu
vas rire c'est la première porte
mais oui mais oui machine qu'est ce que
vous avez dans vos petits parce qu'elle
voulait ou du poulet avec wagner c'est
ma passion
monsieur mal élevés je suis pas du
déjeuner vous emmener au merci madame va
vous faire des comptes est pas parce
qu'ils jouent les réussites des
vignerons vous savez faire l'écho donné
l'assaut on va les laisser vous devez
avoir un tas de choses à vous raconter
on est à un point que tu n'imagines pas
mal et venait monsieur lafleur
laissons les à vos propres propos
[Applaudissements]
charmant absolument charmant mais pardon
pas du tout mon genre
vous avez peut-être que je connais ah
oui là mais ça je te l'avais dit quelle
comédienne a dit dans sept mois le
canard de premiers prix de conservatoire
a seulement dit donc si elle te ment
elle me ment par conséquent l um en tant
qu elle nous manque c'est qu'elles
tiennent encore à nous c'est à partir du
moment où elle nous manque plus que la
situation devient désespérée elle sont
monstrueuses mais non mais non mais
c'est l'amour qui est monstrueux l'amour
ne souffre pas la solitude dont il a
besoin de liberté mais de liberté
surveillée
bon moi je vais porter les valises dans
la chambre parce que je suppose que
c'est là qu'on va dormir avec nikon quoi
un maintien bien dit que tu as accepté
de l'héberger
mais tout à l'heure quand je pensais que
nicole était d'équité mais maintenant
face à bah maintenant raison plus parce
que j'ai piqué une telle colère quand
j'ai appris que nicole avait découché
que j'ai donné mon congé à mon
appartement alors tu vas quand même pas
nous laisser dans la rue avec les
difficultés de logement actuel enfin
nous l'allons tout de même pour vivre
avec la même femme
mais il en est pas question chacun la
sienne dans mon sac à la sienne avant
tout à dix coups et mwaniki enfin mais
la femme est différente avec chaque
homme
et puis de toute façon pas de discussion
pas de tout ce qui arrive maintenant
c'est ta faute ccg mahfoud à moi je
t'adore adore non mais c'est pas bien
mais c'est pas beau mais tu en trouveras
des mariquita mêleront leurs femmes à
domicile non mais c'est pas ça va quand
je pense que je vais passer l'amitié
avant l'amour mais parfaitement avant
l'amour alors que toi tu fais passer de
l'amour avant l'amitié très propre et
que j'écoute je veux dire une chose de
toute façon c'est pas grave parce qu'à
partir du moment où une femme vit avec
son amant elle le considère très vite
comme son arbre bas
vous passez le poulet ou hachoirs au
hachoir démoniaque très bien vous
permettez monsieur est bas de ma vie à
tout voir saler poivrer
malaxez de barras maman du pain rassis
mais alors qu'il avait raison hoyé de
craintes exprimées exprimés et d'accra
jaune donne moi de les les médailles
bureau les médias pensent que ces jeunes
on dirait de la tapisserie des données
on est soigné tu te remets ça pour être
soigné mais attendez attendez attendez
ce n'est pas fini pour le reste le
dessert je vous réserve une surprise de
mon invention c'est si bon c'est bon
j'ai appelé moi tu es gâtés bonsoir
combler ce qu'ils sont mignons tous les
deux mois la moue ça me bouleverse
c'est bien simple depuis maman j'ai
jamais rencontré une femme qui plaisent
autant que vous c'est curieux mais il
semblerait qu'une femme cromer patois
garde va bien tu sais si presque femme
fidèle compagne pas madame
[Applaudissements]
tu veux que je te dise 1 et les
délicieuses data oui elle est ciblée
voilà à quoi tout cas je fais bien la
cuisine et les noms et on l'a foutu
d'hier soir quel merveilleux parce qu'il
ya d'agréables avec vous c'est que vous
êtes toujours content mais des comme toi
on en fait plus tous les jours du cheikh
au début où nous nous sommes connus elle
m'apporte m et croissants chauds tous
les matins au lit elle continue pour
nous deux maintenant celui fait deux
étages mais maintenant maintenant c'est
seulement dimanche parce que c'est très
mauvais de trop gâté les armes mais
c'est un gros défaut ça il n'y a plus de
bordeaux va évidemment tattoo but
maintenant acheter mon vieux quoi encore
bah oui quand tu fais un petit morceau
de tarte mon chéri a volontiers nous non
pas toi à l'horizon à la royauté chez
nikko ajouté pas honneur et pas trop
gros voilà je vous trouve pas trop homme
de goût non non surtout depuis que vous
êtes là depuis quinze jours
madame nicole et monsieur jacques il
s'occupe selon bien de vous que bientôt
on voudrait être aussi masse comme chez
eux à flot elle est maintenant c'est à
moi même père servir alors que ce qui
pourrait bien faire plaisir
voyons voir
merci amour avec un s
dis donc qu'est ce que tu as sur le dos
la sacem schamus de l'agréable
on écoute de match m elles détiennent
oui j'espère au mais j'ai deux mots
c'est pas vrai bien qu est-ce qui fait
quoi ben je vais travailler à non non
non non en prix après le déjeuner tout
alors c'est très bon pour ta digestion
lan est je vous vois vous là bas vous
voir jeu absurde pas besoin j'ai deux
bébés c'est par allez vous avez bien
raison les dorloter des hommes comme ça
ça court pas les rues
si douce et compréhensive attendu moi si
je n'avais pas peur que les 11 me
flanque une route c'est bien ce que je
suis pas les cons petit cousin
au fait vous savez que dans la maison à
son la loose à lui tapent dessus
ah oui oui vous tapez dessus surtout la
locataire du cinquième là il savait la
femme du professeur gradation celle qui
reçoit les petits élèves de son mari
s'ébattaient plus acharnés contre vous
et encore vous avec deux hommes nommés
syndicales à raison de deux inscriptions
par jour
eh bien depuis que les 11 a dit partout
que vous habitiez tous les trois
ensemble est bien là si les trois fois
la pétition oui ou fish a en plus vite
ça c'est pour vous dire que moi dans
l'immeuble jouer les censeurs
moi je suis comme vous monsieur jacques
monsieur que vous moi je suis une
artiste alors j'ai plus de compréhension
ah ben voilà je mettrais un peu plus de
rougeurs oui oui oui vous savez que moi
j'ai fait partie de la comédie française
non oui c'est moi qui blanchissait et
ceux ci étaient bons c'est même là que
j'ai connu et 11 oui en inde que je l'
ai connu il était pompier de service
il ya alors un soir un figurant noir
était malade alors il la remplace au
pied levé et la du mérite vous savez pas
ce que c'est pas facile a comme ne s'est
pas avoir et noir ben il est obligé de
se perdre
alors qu'est-ce qu'on arrive les un
triomphe gilad
surtout quand des s'est retourné
bien de ce padd le dos pas forcément
c'est pas un écran professionnelle alors
mais où ils sont tous
besson partie voilà c'est comme ça qui
me remercient de ma compréhension bon
avec moi je voulais voir si gentil robot
boules parce qu'avec lui au moins est de
la conversation peut pas fonctionner
aussi bien y'a pas s'attaquer aux lé
pape est à mc n 1 elle n'a pas une norme
tabac keith kouna el allam de la pièce
c'est vrai que c'est je su matérialiser
dans ton décor l'impalpable la la pureté
de l'oeuvre doit avoir su garder sa
fraîcheur enfantine comme nous deux pour
bien faire ressentir et les sentiments
souterrain de l'âme très important l'âme
j'aime tellement j'aime tellement ce que
dit le jeune premier front tous et le
bonheur que c'est le bonheur
c'est un bon fruit qu'on croque puis un
jour on tombe sur un noyau et on se
casse une dent n'en garde pas comme ça
on dirait un charmeur de serpents
dix mois plus tôt la phrase de franck
franck oui les jeunes hommes de la pièce
c'est toi là c'est tout à fait toi
bonheur c'est un bon fruit qu'on croque
et bien jour on tombe sur des lèvres de
belles lèvres du pénitent jatte
tu es fou cours avec toi enfin branche
mois mais et françois franchement
françois gourd laval justement ce très
pénible d'être au courant
enfin tu n'as aucune dignité
jacques poux pas qu'elle a quelque chose
de changé
elle a de la dignité tu avais marre elle
le tout c'est le directeur qui s'était
présenté à oui j'ai rendez-vous et plus
demain et ben attash d'enlever la faire
parce que je laisse sans voix cette
affaire
alors à nous elle mademoiselle oui je
trouverai un taxi vite pour le 25 rue
jacob babylone 2,67 j'attends merci et
l'exportation des chemises et et où ça
me laisse a beaucoup joué à rien comme
d'habitude on écoute tu m'as demandé à
jacques de composer des dessins
érotiques sur l'école les ponts et
plastron roule on rendra salle douzaine
de sensations avec l'amérique et le
brésil tu feras désert et badoit dont tu
sais françois je suis comme toi là les
affaires avant tout les pieds sur la
terre
il supporte très bien le reste trois
mois j'ai la tête sur les épaules et
grâce à toi mon chéri parce que la
poésie c'est bien joli quand on a 18 ans
mais enfin on dit dont j'ai une autre
idée pour les chiffres
non je dirais plus tard ça tue en pleine
forme et c'est parce que j'ai fourni
d'idées en ce moment est incroyable et
sera absent tout ça ce à quoi tout ça
oui j'ai dû prendre un petit kilo c'est
pas mal pour ce soir
je sais que tu peux avoir ton fils
préféré des poteaux joubaud non toi
françois enfin j'ai bien le droit de
s'embrasser non un passage à knokke du
vichy recharge ont fouillé tout mais tu
ne ferais beaucoup de peine s'ils
savaient mais qu'est ce que le taux
courants non non non non mais elle sait
pas vous combien dans 5 minutes bon
merci beaucoup
enfin si jacques nous voyez ça lui
apprendra rien et coûte donc une pudeur
[Musique]
c'est vrai quoi tu as raison tu as
raison là là quelque chose de changé
elle a de la pudeur mot fin ce soir
bo battu prendre le thé chez lui cet au
revoir les jumeaux à à quoi en rang eh
ben elle prend le thé chez son alibi lui
s'est taillé à profit plus sérieuse
c'est un vrai chapron cornic oui oui oui
les chaperons rouges qui l'amène au
grand méchant loup
kadi dont à propos de chapon tu peux
être satisfaites à tomber effectuez la
autres nicole moines s'est rien passé
we have a souhaité rempiler avec moi non
plus je pense qu'elle nous oblige à
dormir dans ce wagon lit pendant qu elle
s'enferme dans la chambre du fond alors
je t'aime bien enfin quand même faut pas
exagérer un temps de repasser bulls
non moi avec lui je pouvait causer pas
comme certains comme certains qui sont
pas très contents mais sur lesquels il
ya beaucoup à dire sur monsieur dit je
suis claqué claqué claqué je sors de
révision se maquille à cette chaleur eau
donnez moi ça m'a pris beauté bonjour
mes chéris non messieurs dames
au moins ça fait plus on a toujours bien
su quand on arrive ici dit dans toi
maroc du trois épreuves où il est
présentement il ya si tu aimes tant que
ça les femmes ne les imitent pas pendant
une bulle est fou mais tu es fou
l'homme et la femme sont pas du tout
faits l'un pour l'autre regarder les
feux d'hiver vous verrez on remarquer à
marquer c'est pas comme vous ayez du
sinistre auquel famille unie c'est pas
croyab vous cite en exemple à tous mes
amis et moi aussi mais simplement beaux
jours des noces
pourquoi elle peut jouer dans le mariage
c'est le cas
tous les halls ou touloulou
alors tout le monde a signé la pétition
voici la demande d'expulsion alors vous
avez demain la visite de l'huissier
je voudrais bien c'est parce que vous
nous reprochez ce castor eagle toutes
les villes comme le professeur de
natation et sa boîte femmes
non mais vous m'accusiez d'un crime
passionnel y at il eu crime passionnel
ben c'est justement ce que je reproche à
la barre ça pète ça gueule ça explose
moi monsieur j'ai bâti ma femme pendant
15 ans et ben si elle fait et maintenant
elle aime ça et j'ai eu 12 m 12
entendez 12 j'ai toujours respecté le
domicile conjugal et ça c'est la société
et vous vous êtes contre la société et
moi les gens qui sont contre la société
alors je les excuses avait alors vous
allez préférer que j'ai gorge ma femme
et que je révèle veris mon meilleur ami
ça aurait été logique et surtout plus
viril à pascal à moi je vais vous faire
une confidence
le crime passionnel je suis pour
ben moi je suis content un type qui tue
parce qu'il a faim il explique c'est son
estomac qu'il pousse au crime et celui
qui tue par amour il en a pas la moindre
il n'a pas le droit de toucher à des
sentiments qui le dépasse à des
anarchistes
ce sont des anarchistes alors alors vous
vous roulez la fin de la fin du monde
quoi vu que le franchement tito elop les
journaux données supprimées des crimes
passionnels des jambes pour le lecteur
s'en tenir à il élira plus alors qu'ils
l'ont alors plus d'avocats plus de
magistrats aps plus de policiers et
l'histoire de france ce patrimoine
national
supprimez les crimes passionnels de
l'histoire de france vous supprimez la
moitié des noms mais celle là c'est la
petite histoire de l'histoire de france
alors on n'est pas fous celle là elle a
raconté aux enfants alors est ce que
vous êtes vous êtes aussi contre
l'histoire de france et contre l'accueil
en naturel on est une génération
quel manque de virilité
en tout cas moi je ne vois pas ce que
vient faire les guerres dans kent
passionnément bolide dans le crime
passionnel c'est la guerre à trois mêmes
bras si ce dont on est moins nombreux
mais deux hommes et une femme qui ne se
battent pas alors ça ça c'est hors
nature ça vous ne vous êtes contre
nature je ne sais pas si c'est contre
nature mais en tout cas nous on fiche la
paix à tous les gens de la maison et
c'est justement ce que je reproche votre
silence
il est indécent
du monde n'ont pas grand monde chantait
no nora ci n'a ici une grande chanteuse
ça me super ah ouais bravo bravo nom
jacques bravo ça vraiment alors c'est
très réussi c'est la robe pour le
troisième acte oui mais c'est pour ça
que c'est super pour le 3-2 la walkyrie
révèle télé mais j'adore la walkyrie
mlle superbe donc vous êtes cantatrice
mais oui mais marta von bergen et
j'adore les cantatrices mme quelle
coïncidence n'est ce pas jean monnet
visite à vos charmants voisins parce que
j'habite sur le panier et je vais vous
faire une confidence moi j'adore j'adore
le bel canto jeu chez moi tous les
opéras les opéras comiques avec la
callas tebaldi annie cordy
je vais m'en si vous vouliez dire un
instant avec moi voyez vous mon métier
me laisse quelques loisirs et je me suis
amusé à bricoler un petit magnétophone
et j'aimerais beaucoup mais alors
beaucoup pendant que ghislaine est
coincé dans l'ascenseur de procéder sur
vous un enregistrement de votre superbe
organes
elle ne parle pas français
vous ne parlez pas français on parle pas
du tout
pourtant elle elle le parle quand elle
au chant et ne le chante pas quand elle
devient oui dites moi vous parler
l'allemand non pas du tout
ah bin là il ya un problème à traiter
d'égal avant d'entamer enregistré
renault magnette enfants de l accès aux
non non non mais enfin tu es fou et sa
répétition aux est une artiste de cette
qualité n'a pas besoin de cette aide les
cieux si vous le permettez je vais en
l'air je vous en prie madame elle est
super beautiful
c'est curieux vous frappez quelqu'un non
ces femmes superbes
l'épaule lafleur les ministres passent
mais la police reste non mais c'est
épouvantable enfin que tu te rends pas
compte de la catastrophe quand il va
s'apercevoir que j'étais un homme mais
coûte cette année évidemment tu me
raconteras sa [ __ ] quoi tu es seul dans
un moment pareil mais oui les affaires
m'appelle me faire ça à moi une évidence
après tout ce que j'ai fait pour toi
c'est vrai ça mon vieux je te remercie
enfin tu n'en fais pas un jour où
l'autre sens voudrait ça j'aime bien ça
pourvu que ça dure
d'ailleurs ça ça a l'air de l'etrat de
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la catastrophe mondiale martin martin
téléphone téléphone schnell
elle fait suite à deux mois dans l'état
reconnu les nouvelles parcours avec moi
le combat n'est pas fatale obsédé mais
qu'est ce que c'est battu sur par le
jardin tête je suis envoûté
littéralement entendre qu'elle favorable
aux qu'elle voit quel talent quelle
prestance qu'elle féminité c'était
extraordinaire incroyable
à 50 ans vous rendez compte à 50 ans la
la libération de ma vie quelle est la
révélation de votre vie comme martha
phone bayreuth soit frédéric lafleur
voilà
voilà écouter sans sembler bien qu'elle
n'était pas comme les autres à tuchan
pas tant pis qu'est-ce que vous
tant pis dès 12 ans prieur pas un mot de
ceux ci que ceux ci restent bien entre
nous je ne tiens pas essentiellement
être ridiculisée dans l'immeuble et
surtout aux yeux de ghislaine qui va
bientôt sortir de l'ascenseur alors
j'oublie tout
vous oubliez tout pour la pétition je
m'arrangerais malaxe mais fair terme à
ces [ __ ] qui voulez-vous faire
expulser alors que cette conversation
reste strictement entre nous n'est ce
pas de compte je n'avais pas saisi leur
rapport
elle passa alors moi qui ai gagné le
pays au nom au nom non ce n'est pas ça
le pire le pire le voilà l ont pas
encore une affaire interne habitude oui
oh oui je perds mais non mais fermé côté
gauche il va la fermer
oui je sais pourquoi mais l'affairé raté
parce que je n'ai même pas eu le temps
d'aller jusqu'à mon rendez vous en
sortant de chez toi je passais devant un
hôtel discret avant parce que tu te fais
affaire dans les maisons dans des voûtes
je te dis je passais jeu peut même
ajouter que j ai vu rentrer une femme de
notre connaissance dans cette
accueillante maison femme blonde avec un
ensemble bleu dit rien et qui s'appelle
nicole avec piété tél alors le comble je
connais pas jeudi le comble virgule
parce que c'est un comble il avait été
emprisonné mais vous allez lui sauter
dessus que j'ai pas le temps ils m'ont
échappé alors moi j'ai fait tous les
étages en commençant par la vidéo
message peu dingue à oui évidemment
violeur en plus moi je voulais pas
provoquer de scandale étant donné ma
situation
j'avais été le mari je dis pas non mais
qu'est ce que tu dis là qu'est ce que tu
as dit non non mais répète un peu pauvre
voilà l'été je n'étais pas son mari est
pas son mari non chaque fête est
compliqué nicolet - toi de toi j'ai tout
accepté tout parce que pour moi être la
mort d'une femme marié c'était la grande
aventure la peur l'amour aux aguets dans
les pattes manker l'accord de liste dans
la nuit des courses folles pour échapper
au baril sanguinaire mais non mais coûte
à tétouan j'ai accepté que tu partages
ma vie la femme de même à tous même
parce que je me disais tu vas le bon
rôle tu es le vainqueur mais c'est le
malade faut le ménager en nylon jetant
prélat de toi tais toi j'ai accepté qu
après chaque douche tu transformes assad
de bord pis il dit que c'est peut-être
pas exporter des nouvelles peintures tu
les essais sur les murs de ma chambre et
tu la transforme en rased
mais bon ça c'est de là que c'est parler
qu'est-ce que je dois lire moi nous ne
sommes pas mariés
n'étant pas son mari chemin points à
copuler gallardo et moi j'y peux rien
parce que quand tu dors avec une femme
mariée
vous tapez elle sonne avant une femme
qui n'est pas qu'on appelle son ami la
nuit c'est bien ce que je suis devenu
non moi je vais dire le pu tromper des
dossiers pas toi c moi c'est moi tu a
trompé qui a trompé la confiance la
confiance que tu
il reste c'est à jacques tu perds mais
je peux tu expliquer face y voilà il
colle et moi nous avions vraiment
l'attention nous marier la preuve c'est
qu'il ya trois mois
je lui ai donné rendez vous à la mairie
du 16e j'ai attendu trois heures et
c'était trompait m'attendais à celle de
huitième alors comme je savais que tu
tenais à ton titre d' à manger rien
voulu me dire pendant de faire de peine
enfin si ça peut te consoler a pu lever
toujours à mes yeux
- moi qui ai accepté que tu
m'envahissent actes et sign up be blood
famille tient là parce que j'en fais
vote à son nom de province en france a
et babol petit chat est mort salo coince
à l'eau non seulement qu'une troupe est
une tâche mais céramique moi oui c'est
tout ça lourd de me [ __ ] le camp tient
le salon quoi j'aime mes gars d'ailleurs
je ne sais pas pourquoi je devrais je
suis chez moi et si tu m'entends
chez moi je les vois parfaitement mais
parfaitement tués edwards oui nous
sommes chez nous mais qu'est ce qui vous
prend au mot qui me dépêcher de rentrer
pour faire un bon dîner lucette viennent
de l'unrwa cette formidable si bien
pourquoi je doute
elle a déménagé lucette les déménager
elle habite 13 rue girardot lui cette
girafe dont elle était dans l'hôtel de
la rue girardot ça c'est ignoble vois
pas ce que ça change
la première foire c'est moi qui ai
emmené nicole dans l'hôtel que là haut
j'ai ordonné d'aller mieux en mieux
maintenant peut-être dans la même sans
vol mais avant de connaître
je ne savais même pas que ça existait ce
genre d'établissement tu n'avais qu'à
pas mieux mais ce n'est pas en mai mais
ce n'est pas andré j habitais si j'avais
les peintres alors comme j'avais les
palha me foutent des pins doit savoir
c'est avec kireta dans cette tomate a
tenté de dire ça c'était un homme qui
total charles en revanche compris avec
et et u13 gerardo s'efface ou une femme
honnête mois
avec qui où les égos que je soins avec
mon mari
avec ton mari avec ton mari avec son
mari mais lequel les 100 valdoisienne
coupal mois a été mariée non mais tu
entends ça oh oh elle était mariée elle
est mariée à les marquer tu es marié je
suis marié à les marier
m'est avis qu'ils veulent être sûrs
d'être abattu tous complètement mais qui
sait cette chaîne se marie parce que moi
virtuellement je continuerai canton
marié toit virtuellement
qu'est ce que tu fabriques de cet hôtel
moi je te suivait ça t'apprendra c'est
tout c'est tout ce que tu trouves à
répondre parce que ma bouche c'était
pensez vous que mon coeur rapport aux
admirables
c'est tout cet admirable c'est admirable
malheureusement ces points d'elle c'est
d'andré gide
ah oui comme le mensonge ne prend plus
elle va nous sortir toutes les citations
qu'elle connaît le dictionnaire entier
vais y penser
vous avez été mes deux passions on peut
avoir deux passions on n'est jamais des
amours blancs
alexandre dumas fils
non je suis une femme fidèle et 10 dont
une femme fidèle qui a un mari et deux
amants alors qu'est ce que doivent être
les autres elles sont infidèles
oui mais une femme infidèle et souvent
beaucoup plus fidèle qu'une femme fidèle
parce que l'infidélité
mais c'est une fidélité un même idéal à
la recherche d'un même amour
ah bon c'est 2 10 à 2 mois
alors si je comprends bien jacques ton
mari et toi et moi nous sommes fondu
dans un soleil mais exactement
tenez allait ouvrir cette technique
comment lui et pour la pétition tout est
arrangé vous m'avez avec la cantatrice
bonjour monsieur qu'est ce qu'il sait
que c'est sa grille nos jours pour
écoutez moi moi on va une fois mais pas
deux autant avec martha fans bayreuth je
pouvais faire est rare mais là y'a pas à
tromper un sacré gaillard des temps
quand votre petite copine reviendra
faites moi signe
au fond un bon ghislaine bouche cousue
qu'est ce que tu fais tu t'en vas
oui je vais retrouver michel niche
encore un autre mais non michel ces
moments écoute ça fait deux ans que je
n'ai pas lu et tu nous fais tu veux nous
faire croire que tu pars pour aller
retrouver un homme quand t'as pas vu
depuis deux ans et à qui la faute à qui
la faute si j'ai pas vu depuis deux ans
alors alors ça c'est admirable elle a
tous les torts mais elle va s'arranger
pour faire croire que c'est moi qui les
ai dit oui mais ça mon vieux c'est la
meilleure tactique fait mignon mais vous
voyez je voulais partir sans drame et
j'avais même préparé mes valises en
cachette pour pas vous faire de peine
non il faut me croire c'est vrai ça fait
deux ans que j'ai pas vu michel et c'est
vrai que j'ai retrouvé tout à fait par
hasard
mais oui tout à fait par hasard j'ai
retrouvé son numéro de téléphone
j'ai pas pu m'empêcher de l'appeler oui
bien sûr c'est normal on s'est revus
avant-hier et ça a été la révélation du
seuil dans l'aberration de quoi mais la
révélation de la mer la bombe alors
pourquoi l'avoir quittée et les
hépatites et je suis parti mais c'est
une lance
mais oui je suis parti parce que je
pensais que je n'aimais pas suffisamment
alors je suis parti toujours par
fidélité à l'amour que je porte et moi
c'est logique
oh non mais l'illogisme des femmes va
finir par devenir plus logique que la
logique de l'homme
franchement pourquoi j'étais rencontrer
et j'étais suivi
tu sais pourquoi je t'ai suivi je
suppose parra mauresque par passionnera
qui a été ma première passion
je t ai suivi parce que tu as cette
confiance dans la vie c'est surtout
cette solidité camichel
mais que tu le veuilles ou non françois
tu es tu es un peu michel mais je me
repens toi et moi alors mais toi je t'ai
suis pas ce que tu as est je laisse
cette poésie qu'a su garder michel et
qui lui donne tant de charme et puis
hier dans les bras de michel à la la
j'ai tout compris
inconsciemment j'acceptais de vivre
entre nous deux parce que vous deux
réunis mais vous êtes mon mari ce numéro
là je ne le connaissais pas mais alors
bravo est admirable tu sais c'est plus
réussis laurent
en fait pourquoi m'as-tu caché que
françois n'était pas mon mari mais du
coup parce qu'une femme qui a un mari un
amant c'est normal ça
la société l'acceptent tandis qu'une
femme qu'à deux amants on n'accepte
jamais fois tout seul tu es incroyable
mais ça tu te trouveras toujours de
bonnes raisons mais je ne cherche pas à
me justifier je ne suis pas si différent
des autres fin au non au nom au nom pire
mais elles courent tout après un seul et
même amour
seulement il ya les hypocrites qui
préfèrent le rêve et le grand amour moi
je suis de celles qui veulent le vibre
et ben voila avis le document comprend
alors vas-y ville entre regrettera quand
même aussi sûrement plus bout parce que
je vais pas vous faire de reproches mais
on accepte partager une femme c'est
qu'on aime vraiment cas motivés
au revoir françois parent sont à rosine
3 citrons par jour sans sucre mais avec
pépin avec toi chez tranquille tu es
tellement raisonnable tu veilles bien
sûr lui tu travailles bien c'est quand
même grâce à moi vous vous êtes retrouvé
alors vous allez me promettre une chose
c'est que vous vous quitterai plus
jamais aussi promis on te le promets non
merci
allez va où il va
finissons-en bah écoute c'est pas un
problème on va t'aider
non mais c'est pas causer vanille c'est
parce que je me bats partir qu'est ce
que j'aime venir
enfin on est là mais non non non il faut
m'aider il faut m'aider parce qu'il faut
que j'aille retrouver michel je vous
aime trop vous comprenez je n'ai aussi
au tome 3 wii écoute c'est à tel point
que jacques et moi femme moi et jacques
non je crois que si on voudrait bien de
garder ma on ferait n'importe quoi pour
ça c'est vrai c'est vrai parce que je
vous aime parce que je vous aime tous
les deux c'est vrai vous voulez bien que
j'aille la chercher mais oui chan vous
allez voir vous allez voir comment va
être heureux tous les cas
[Applaudissements]
mr pièces que nous venons de jouer
devant vous et de jacques bernard
[Applaudissements]
le décor et la maquette et de jean
pierre soler et patrick galois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les costumes sont de donald cardwell
avec jacques mauclair qui a réglé la
mise en scène
monique tarbaise
[Applaudissements]
jacques bernard
sacha briquet
[Applaudissements]
dominique paturel
et jacqueline gauthier
[Applaudissements]
n
je sais pas
m
[Musique]